[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos sobre la nueva ley de
reducción de la inflación de Estados
Unidos una ambiciosa iniciativa pero que
algunas cuestiones preocupan a Bruselas
porque podría ser discriminatoria hacia
la industria Europea y dañar su
competitividad ya muy tocada desde la
pandemia y por los altos precios de la
energía antes de pasar al debate hacemos
un repaso sobre los aspectos de esta ley
que tanto preocupan a la Unión Europea
la ley de reducción de la inflación de
Estados Unidos se trata de una de las
iniciativas más ambiciosas para luchar
contra la crisis climática hasta ahora
con un plan de inversión de 370 mil
millones de dólares Apuesta por el
fomento de las energías limpias y verdes
en detrimento de los combustibles
fósiles
a pesar de que la medida se percibe como
positiva en la Unión Europea preocupan
algunas de las disposiciones de la ley
el paquete incluye ayudas masivas que
según Bruselas podrían distorsionar la
competencia y es discriminatoria para
las compañías europeas preocupa
especialmente las exenciones y créditos
Fiscales para los consumidores que
compren automóviles eléctricos de
fabricación norteamericana una lógica de
Bio American muy arraigada en el país
que no gusta Europa con una industria
del automóvil muy fuerte con grandes
países exportadores como Alemania o
Francia Bruselas hasta ahora siempre ha
pedido que los vehículos europeos no
sufran la discriminación de la misma
forma que tampoco les afecta la ley a
los canadienses y mexicanos hasta ahora
Washington se ha negado ante la
situación la comisión europea ya ha
preparado una serie de medidas que
mitiguen el impacto que puede tener en
la industria y la competitividad europea
pero a pesar de las tensiones Bruselas y
Washington mantienen el diálogo y niegan
que esto implique una guerra comercial
y para analizar Cuáles son las
consecuencias de esta controvertida ley
estadounidense tenemos a la eurodiputada
del grupo socialdemócrata Lina Gálvez
bienvenida Lina Hola
y con la eurodiputada del grupo renovar
Europa y con Bilbao bienvenida izas con
muchas gracias a las dos por estar aquí
por vuestro tiempo cuando yo baiden
accedió a la presidencia la Unión
Europea pensó que hay que ya enterar el
hacha de guerra se habían despedido ya
de Donald Trump pero esta ley de
reducción de la inflación ha despertado
un malestar inesperado la Unión Europea
ha pecado de ingenua con Estados Unidos
Lina
Bueno yo creo que la Unión Europea no se
entiende Si en Estados Unidos y siempre
ha sido un socio principal y prioritario
y lo va a seguir siendo porque no puede
ser de otra manera lo cierto verdad es
que la globalización tal y como la
conocíamos ha cambiado y Estados Unidos
lo que ha hecho ha sido adaptarse y
digamos en un actor principal en esos
cambios no y ha hecho pues sí una ley
que no tiene nada que ver con la
inflación con la reducción de la
inflación sino que es principalmente una
ley de para la reindustrialización y
sobre todo para la transición verde y
para Bueno pues para para fomentar que
se produzca las cosas en Estados Unidos
sea de empresas norteamericanas sean de
empresas extranjeras y aquí es donde de
alguna forma viene el problema porque
tienen unas condiciones tal vez mejores
que que nosotros no el precio de la de
la energía el propio mercado interno que
tiene tienen una la moneda de referencia
en fin tiene una demografía más dinámica
que tienen una serie digamos de ventaja
que les permiten Bueno pues hacer este
tipo de políticas que evidentemente
bueno pues son unos subsidios a esas
empresas que van a competir
preferentemente en los mercados
internacionales Pero y esto creo que es
puede ser casi también lo más
problemático para para la Unión Europea
que puede atraer una inversión directa
extranjera
que no venga a la Unión Europea o
incluso de empresas europeas que
acabendose allí o el talento europeo que
ahora mismo Pues escasea no como como he
dicho antes por este invierno
demográfico hacia el que estamos yendo
Entonces yo creo que más que quejarnos
no que también debemos Bueno si tenemos
unas reglas no establecidas
internacionales y queremos jugar con esa
regla vamos a jugar todos con la con las
mismas reglas lo que pasa es que es
verdad que antes tampoco se jugaba todo
con las mismas reglas pero lo que
tenemos que hacer pues reaccionar lo que
se está haciendo Tal vez un poco un poco
tarde pero se está reaccionando
y sobre todo intentar encajar bien esa
asociación o esa relación con Estados
Unidos porque en esta globalización que
ahora es mucho más segmentada el
hemisferio oeste para que nos entendamos
va a seguir funcionando de manera
integrada quizás con Sí yo creo que
comparto que Estados Unidos es un socio
fundamental y lo que hay que considerar
es que Estados Unidos ha sufrido los
mismos problemas de la globalización el
covid Por cierto muy mal gestionado por
el anterior presidente Donald Trump que
ha dejado unas consecuencias que han
sido seguramente mucho más graves que en
Europa y que bueno Tiene que enfrentarse
efectivamente a las consecuencias que
también allí ha generado la invasión de
Rusia en Ucrania y una transformación en
la que estamos todos metidos no una
transformación
ecológica otros tipos de energía digital
y luego con una falta de modelo social
que no se conoce como en Europa y por lo
tanto yo creo que se han visto obligados
a poner herramientas para primero
enfrentarse a esa problemática que ha
generado las crisis que estamos viviendo
todos Y en segundo lugar porque
efectivamente se ha dado cuenta igual
que nos hemos dado cuenta en Europa Pues
que necesitan reindustrializar
modernizar y hacer que transite esa
industria tan fuerte en Estados Unidos y
además yo creo que esto con una
perspectiva de futuro también de caras
de Cara a evitar los populismos que ya
Donald Trump está utilizando desde hace
tiempo no somos cada vez más pobres en
nuestra economía es un desastre Entonces
ha tenido que reaccionar esto quiere
decir que bueno pues hay una ruptura no
efectivamente a nosotros no gustado en
la manera en la que se ha hecho eso pero
efectivamente debemos mirar qué podemos
hacer nosotros creo que y espero que el
diálogo de futuro pueda tener un
resultado tenemos que pensar en nuestras
propias herramientas que como ha dicho
Lina se están poniendo ya en marcha
nosotros tenemos que acelerar nuestro
modelo tenemos que acelerar nuestro
modelo
Industrial e industrial digitalizado y
sostenible y sobre todo reforzar nuestro
modelo social y esto es lo que nos va a
hacer más competitivos en el mundo
porque
lo que está claro es que no hay otro
modelo similar en el que podamos
equilibrar el desarrollo económico con
el desarrollo social y afortunadamente
estas crisis que hemos vivido han
reforzado también el modelo social a
nivel europeo y lo van a hacer más en el
futuro Así que hay que seguir cooperando
y hay que seguir trabajando y tenemos
que ir construyendo nuestras propias
herramientas y tratar de solventar con
diplomacia y diálogo pues este pequeño
bache que tenemos justamente quizás con
hacías mención a las ayudas de estado
Que es el modelo que está haciendo
Estados Unidos y es algo que también se
está planteando la comisión europea
tiene varias propuestas en mente y una
de ellas es pues facilitar y también
flexibilizar el modelo de que los países
europeos puedan dar ayudas públicas a la
industria también a las empresas y
evitar por ejemplo que empresas europeas
de Ciudad marcharse a Estados Unidos
Entonces es necesario esta reforma
algunos países tienen dudas Francia y
Alemania Siempre han sido las más
beneficiadas Lina yo creo que que sí es
que si es necesario de nuevo porque las
reglas internacionales están cambiando
Estados Unidos china ya la has cambiado
de alguna manera Estados Unidos también
las está cambiando y por tanto Nosotros
también las tenemos que cambiar y además
porque para hacer la transición sobre
todo tanto la digital pero sobre todo la
ecológica hace falta mucho dinero
mucho dinero y con mucho riesgo y por
tanto hace falta que que digamos haya
más dinero público hay sobre todo cuando
hablamos de la innovación que tiene que
ser central en todo este en todo este
proceso dicho lo cual Ese proceso lo
tenemos que hacer de manera que no
aumente las desigualdades porque los
países no estamos en la misma situación
y como no hay una Unión fiscal Pues
claro Va a depender también de la
capacidad fiscal de cada país y los
países estamos en situaciones muy
distintas y por tanto la capacidad
fiscal que tiene Alemania no es por
ejemplo la que tiene España no por no
irnos tampoco a un país muy pequeño no y
por tanto la capacidad que va a tener
Alemania para ayudar que ya lo está
haciendo que ya lo hizo durante la covid
que recordemos que Alemania es el país
que más
ayudas ha dado después Francia y luego
ya un poco más alejado de Italia ya
luego el resto y claro eso es equilibra
completamente el mercado interno por
tanto hay que tener mucho cuidado con
esto sabemos que hay un enfrentamiento
también entre entre comisario bueno la
vicepresidenta vestagger que quiere que
esta que esta flexibilización no Sea
temporal y bretón que claro que como
comisario de Industria No pues ve más
este largo plazo y dice no esto tiene
que ser más continuado pero claro si es
más continuada hay que ver cómo se
diseña para que no aumente las
desigualdades porque se aumentan todavía
más las desigualdades
dentro de la Unión Europea lo que se
pone en riesgo el propio proyecto
europeo Y eso no lo queremos nadie ni lo
deseamos no tanto hay que diseñarlo muy
bien para que cambiemos ese modelo
porque creo que lo necesitamos pero al
mismo tiempo que lo hagamos con la
suficiente cohesión para que no aumente
los desequilibrios entre entre países
que creo y entre regiones que creo que
es que es un riesgo de hecho una de las
de las características por ejemplo
de la de la ley de reducción de
inflación de Estados Unidos es que está
muy localizada geográficamente
Precisamente en aquellas zonas que han
sufrido más la desindustrialización
aquellas zonas que están más deprimidas
para que no se queden descolgadas y para
que no digamos luego alimenten esos
populismos que quizás conducían la
comisión europea habla de unirse con
Estados Unidos sobre todo para hacer
frente a China que lo que se tiene que
enfocar es no depender tanto de China
por ejemplo en cuestiones como las
tierras raras y materias primas debe ser
el futuro también una red
industrialización Europea
algunos venimos reclamando desde hace
muchísimo tiempo que Europa tiene que
ser mucho más industrial de lo que es
quizá porque nosotros yo procedo de una
región industrial y lo que hemos visto
es que en las crisis por ejemplo del
2008 las regiones industriales en Europa
soportaron mucho mejor el embate de la
crisis Por qué Pues porque
una industria lo que atrae es primero
más Innovación más formación humana
empleos de más calidad más arraigo al
territorio creación de pymes que van
colaborando con esas industrias que en
este momento son ya de 4.0 y por lo
tanto hemos reclamado esa
reindustrialización europea desde hace
mucho tiempo y yo me alegro de que
estemos hablando de esto por qué Pues
porque veíamos que la Competencia por
ejemplo que hacía china con los pasos
que iba dando Pues en algún momento iba
a acabar con el modelo europeo y de
todas las regiones europeas no pero yo
en este momento hablando de
reindustrialización que creo que es
también un movimiento
global y también en Estados Unidos lo
que echo de menos es el acuerdo
comercial que quedó desbancado con
Estados Unidos Pues nos quedamos con
esta idea quizás con Lina nos hemos
quedado sin tiempo pero muchísimas
gracias a los dos a ustedes les
esperamos en el próximo programa de
Europa hoy Gracias por ver France 24 en
español
[Música]